why is it important for writers to
understand that the idea of the story is
not the whole story well I I I do always
say that to my My Writers is that uh
your idea of your story is never the
whole story it's not that the idea is
incorrect it's the the idea is
incomplete all right and so we uh uh
being a writer being a story being an
artist is humbling because you're not
the author you're the channel and um so
when I'm working with writers I'm really
speaking to their higher self I'm I'm
talking I really believe that uh your
subconscious is the seed of your Genius
and the genius is not a noun it's a verb
it's something we all have access to and
so
um you have to let go of your idea of
your story you have to let go of your
ego because as Einstein says you can't
solve a problem at the same level of
Consciousness that created the problem
and every Story begins with an apparent
dramatic problem all right but you can't
solve it at the same level of
Consciousness that created it so what
you've got to do is you've got to you've
got to uh let go of this idea of what
the story is in order for the truth of
the story to
emerge uh if I was to reduce or distill
story structure to three words I'd say
it's desire protagonist has to want
something that Stakes your life and
death if I don't get blank my life will
be unimaginable if Jan Brady doesn't get
a date with Tad Hamilton she will
positively die all right and then
Surrender Your protagonist has to let go
of the meaning they made out of their
goal all right and then finally
transformation so desire surrender
transformation I'm I'm really uh a big
believer in the threea
structure and uh so the First Act is all
about thesis it's it's the argument you
know it's the dramatic question stated
uh act two is about antithesis it's the
drama played out and then act three is
synthesis or integration how can we take
these two seemingly disperate
ideas and that Collide and lead and and
and lead us to a deeper truth so
um uh and and the two these two
seemingly disperate ideas uh involve The
Dilemma so so for example justice
justice would be powerful desire I I I I
want Justice the false belief is that
when I kill my enemy Justice will be
done by the end of the story your
protagonist reframes their relationship
to what Justice means they might
discover that True Justice Means taking
respon discovering perhaps that I'm
complicit in this thing it might be a
mystery story or a thriller where they
discover that in their attempt to
uncover Justice they discover something
about uh their beloved that puts get
that creates a dilemma where if I if I
do kill my enemy I will in some way be
complicit in the
crime now you say that we are uh not the
author or the channel if we take
something let's say like Oppenheimer
amazing film yeah that's based on
someone's life how are we actually a
channel when that life has already
occurred ah it's a great question so if
you gave the Oppenheimer story to 10
writers they're going to write 10
completely different stories right not
completely different I mean they would
have to they would have to be some way
you know gerain to the the events of his
life but the story is not about what
happens it's about the meaning we
ascribe to what happens I'll give you an
example so let's let's just put
Oppenheimer for aside for a second
somebody asked me years ago one of my
students they said you're always talking
about meaning what are you talking about
I said well I'm going to tell you a
story right now I just made something up
and now this is the stupid good example
I always give I'm going to make up a
story I'm going to tell you exactly what
happened but it will be bereft of
meaning so woman comes home says to her
husband uh we've been married 20 years I
want a divorce husband quits his job
gets on a plane flies to France goes out
to a carrot Farm the farmer rushes out
hugs the man and together they open a
carrot juice restaurant called carrot
juice Charlie I just told you exactly
what happened doesn't mean anything so
now here's the story with meaning woman
comes home says to her husband we've
been married 20 years and you're still a
stranger to me the man quits his job and
flies to France which is the last place
he saw his father alive when he was 8
years old he goes out to the carrot Farm
where his father dropped dead of a heart
attack the farmer who was the father's
best friend rushes out and hugs the son
still distraught over his inability to
save the man leaving the boy orphaned
together they open a carrot juice
restaurant in honor of the the boy's
father whose name was Charlie and they
begin the process of
healing so it's not what happens it's
the meaning we ascribe to it I can't
tell you how many writers I work with
that will say um they'll they'll they'll
say well uh my character would never do
that and my answer is always well well
if you have an Impulse if if if an idea
comes to you and you dismiss it because
you think your idea is your character
wouldn't do that you're actually cutting
off the channel your job as a
Storyteller I believe is to support what
your subconscious gives you I can't tell
you how many times I see second acts
start to
Flatline because we get so attached to
our idea of how the story ought to go
that we disconnect from the truth of
what the story wants to be I'll give you
another example I don't know why I
always bring up It's a Wonderful Life
but I don't know if you remember the
midpoint of It's a Wonderful Life but
this is where Mr Potter offers George
Bailey a job now imagine for a moment
that you're
writing this story that would make no
sense logically for the devil for the
the the the primary antagonist to offer
the hero a job because they're in direct
competition with each other but here's
the thing as a Storyteller he doesn't
offer the George Bailey from Act One a
job he offers the George Bailey from the
middle of act two a job this is the
midpoint this is where uh your
protagonist experiences Temptation
between what they want and what they
need and George barley considers taking
the job because this is how we
experience how desperately he wants to
leave Bedford Falls that he would
actually con consider working for the
devil so um this is why story structure
is so important and this is why an
outline particularly in screenwriting is
essential because without an outline
your idea of your story is never going
to get you to the end because you're
going to be so attached to what you
think should happen that you're not
going to uh allow yourself to truly be
surprised by where the characters want
to take you if you're not allowing
yourself to be a little bit embarrassed
a little bit vulnerable You're going to
be protecting yourself in some way the
first exercise I give my writers in the
workshops is the fear I call it the fear
exercise and the exercise is simply I'm
afraid to write this story because you
write for five minutes listing all your
fears and I and then I asked the writer
I go why do you think we do this
exercise and they always go well it's
probably really helpful to become aware
of your fears so they don't rule you and
I go well that's part of it for sure but
here's the deeper truth is the fears you
have in writing your story are identical
in nature to the fears that your
protagonist has in the
story and so when you allow yourself to
be vulnerable on the page and list your
fears in writing the story you
are um you're connecting to the truth of
your story and you're discovering how
you are uniquely qualified to write this
story because you're writing for this
raw vulnerable place I think sometimes
we have this idea of what it means to be
a good writer but um when I work with
writers I stay out of the result it's
all about process and I truly believe
that the story lives fully and
completely within the writer I fully
believe that their subconscious is the
seat of their genius so my job is to
facilitate the writer in finding the
story that already lives fully and
completely within in them so it's it's
it's if you make the thrill of creation
its own reward you're going to uh you're
going to start to get to something
that's really exciting and you've got to
my job is to be curious it's it's the
Socratic method it's just asking
questions and I'll say one other thing
it's got to come from love it's got to
come from openhearted Curiosity it can't
be it can never be curiosity because I
see creative teachers do this sometimes
of
um if it's not coming from a spirit of
play like we're just in the
sandbox we don't have to worry about
anything the writer is going to get
self-conscious and they're going to
protect themselves which is what you're
kind of talking about um and it's so
easy for artists were so there's
something so fragile about this process
so easy for artists to get into their
ego I I'll tell you a funny story Louis
B may created the uh Academy of Motion
Pictures Arts and Sciences in
1929 um because he was afraid
that the actors were going to unionize
because they the they had uh he he had
had the the stage hands build his house
and he had discovered they had just
unionized he goes oh the actors are next
and they're going to ruin
me because when they they unionize
they're going to want a piece of the
action so the Oscars were
created for
strictly uh monetary reasons it was to
save him money he saved millions of
dollars by creating the Academy Awards
the Academy Awards were were he he was
appealing to the actor's
egos as a way of protecting his business
interest award shows when you really
think about it artists don't need Awards
our egos love Awards but we when I was
when I was uh a number of years ago I I
won something called the prepr Tom which
is uh it's it's it's uh in France it's
best foreign novel and I remember I got
flown to Paris and I was I was
um I was for this thing called Festival
America with all these famous authors
and and I remember being in my booth and
uh all these people are around me and
I'm and and and I can feel myself like I
was feeling like a big shot and then I
look up and there's Michael Shaban who
had just won the Pulitzer for ventures
of cavalier and clay
and I remember he had his hands in his
pockets and he was kind of looking at me
with this half smile like dude what are
you doing and he was very sweet but in
that moment I I felt like he saw me and
and I was like
H I forgot why I was there which was
because it wasn't I wasn't being
celebrated my the channel was being
celebrated do you understand what I mean
and
um it's really
dangerous for the artist not to
differentiate between the channel and
the uh which is which is all that
matters and then the the the author
which or the or the
ego